that's the thing when you like when you
look at somebody like Keanu Reeves it
which is like just unbelievable how uh
amazing
he stayed positive how do you stay
positive
how do you stay like we don't know much
about calories but we know every time
you hear about Kennedy's it's of him
doing the nicest thing like people will
be like yeah my dogs County Reeves
[ __ ] literally jumped in front of a
moving train to save my dog or Kennedy's
yeah dude I was talking to counter
Reeves and I mentioned he you know I
mentioned I need like some [ __ ] blood
transfusion and he straight-up drove me
to the hospital and he gave me some
blood I guess it comes from him not you
know what comes from for sure him not
having a Twitter or Instagram encounter
he's had an Instagram or Twitter it'd be
over you get if you have a Twitter and
Instagram you can get cancelled you know
but if you don't you kind of can I mean
you can but not really though because
Sean Connery doesn't have this [ __ ] and
you roll that [ __ ] he said I people were
tweeting about that [ __ ] they didn't
have a Twitter account Witter or an
Instagram people think they can't like
write to you so they're like oh he's not
gonna see it I think they do it when
they're like this mother because my mom
would Sean Connery said about like you
you should slap women ha
and then he doubled down on it he was
having an interview and I was like so
you said you should stop women he's like
yes I think I think that you should I
was like well I don't like that very
much as I will sometimes I reckon up
worst of worst I a [ __ ] impression
ever but like he and and then and then
like people were like we got to cancel
him and then it came out on Twitter a
little bit but then he doesn't have a
Twitter so we were like a [ __ ] it boy
he's not gonna he's old he's old I got
to get rid of my [ __ ] that's the thing I
got to get
point where you look at output that's
the thing I always talk about this it's
like Al Pacino in someone you become
undirected well in your own life that's
what it is
if you're not with a [ __ ] hard go if
you don't have somebody that grounds you
in a real way you go you're done you go
crazy like you need a wife or a [ __ ]
real person that can just bring that's
what that's why that's why actors get so
bad that's why you're like what the [ __ ]
happened to that actor used to be so
good now look what the [ __ ] he's doing
because he was in he got too much of an
ego and then he started being in movies
and the directors couldn't hold him down
that's why every now and then Al Pacino
has a movie or he's just you're like
what the [ __ ] is he doing
he still kills it I mean he's still
brilliant and [ __ ] as an actor
connectors even really brilliant you
know but Al Pacino every now and then
you're like oh he's - Al Pacino because
you can't direct that [ __ ]
unless you're a [ __ ] really good
director directors don't want to let
don't want to tell him they don't be
like can you do it this way because they
know opportunies gonna be like wow and
then you have to have an answer and
you're talking to the legend Al Pacino
De Niro these guys Walken is a great
example really really good but if you
[ __ ] not directing him he it would
just be like wow wow wow and then you'd
be like okay but that's probably cuz
Kincaid you know is probably yeah that's
the thing if you have another out to
lunch [ __ ] person on your team that's
the thing I guess it's about staying
grounded
I don't like figuring the [ __ ] out
before the show by the way I don't like
figuring it out I like talking it out
because we need to figure it out as a
cult because this is a cult dude but
staying positive in the limelight is
amazing staying positive and not losing
your [ __ ] mind like Keanu Reeves died
now granted he's only like 52 but
there's this whole thing about doubling
down though now that like seems to work
because there's so many people out there
on the internet like Trump and everybody
just doubles the [ __ ] down look at just
see someone let any other time in
history
[ __ ] even ten years ago he would have
been like yeah [ __ ] up but he knows
there's enough people out there because
he sees them on the internet that he's
like no I really got [ __ ] jumped even
though you orchestrated the whole
goddamn thing and it was a Saddam we
know we know that he [ __ ] made it up
there's still conspiracy theorists out
there there's enough of them there's
hundreds of thousands of other [ __ ]
that do this that think this and he's
just sitting there nah he knows he's
lying but he's like nah didn't happen I
got mugged and jumped and because of
that people like even real people like
Anthony Anderson and [ __ ] will be like
yeah dude I believe him huh I got quest
my thing is what about the so much
evidence it has to be now though because
it doesn't last like everyone knows oh
gee I didn't do it I mean everyone knows
OJ did it sorry so so it has to be now
if some [ __ ] goes down now there's
enough people to be on your [ __ ] team
because there's too many people in the
world
it's just there's too many people that's
why I think Santos was right you need to
cut the [ __ ] people in half
you saw endgame bro the first one I was
like I'm on Thanos his side look at all
these [ __ ] look at how many [ __ ]
first of all look at me annoying
superheroes there are the half of those
got to go and then some people don't
have superpowers and they're just wheat
their mouths to feed they got a go dude